It went so fast.
I don't know why so many people thought this was a collab.
Sorry to disappoint you, I'm only playing a game.
Because people can't read.
Maybe.
Wow, real Korone on screen.
Oh, Korone-san, what do you have to say?
Welcome to my stream!
She says...
Wow.
She says wow wow.
Just like the game!
Wow wow wow.
Such true words.
Yeah, she said that, for real.
Yeah.
I'm excited to play.
Look at this, this is so cute.
Yubi!
Oh.
One Yubi.
Two Yubi.
Yubi yubi yubi.
Machine gun.
Shotgun.
Bonk bonk bonk hammer.
Wait, she says other things too.
And there's also other weapons to unlock.
I...
I don't know what...
Why...
It looks like a sensor.
Bone?
Okay.
Okayu?
Cat?
I don't know.
Yubi yubi.
Machine gun.
Wow wow wow.
Shotgun.
Yeah.
So we're gonna...
We're just gonna hang out and play for a little bit.
Yeah.
Today's stream won't be super long because I have some stuff that I need to get done.
I got a new...
A new thing to build.
A shelf.
I bought a shelf that I have to build.
And...
Just some other things.
Ikea moment.
Yeah.
Basically.
Thank you for the tiny gift.
Thank you.
But I just wanted to still chill and hang out.
So I'm gonna...
Chill a little bit.
Today.
Yeah.
And I thought this would be perfect.
So we have a couple...
I've never played this before.
It was just officially released.
Like...
A couple days ago.
So...
I do wanna play Holocure.
Because I really like...
I really like...
Vampire Survivor.
And stuff.
So...
Yeah.
Um...
Mint don't read.
Oh.
But yeah.
Um...
Probably we'll...
Try Holocure at some point too.
We'll just do normal mode.
Let's go!
I'm a dog!
Oh.
How do I move?
Is that a thing I've destroyed?
Actually I'm not sure.
Wait.
This way?
Oh.
What's this?
Help me!
Oh.
Ah!
Wait.
What is this thing?
Oh.
Ow!
Oh!
There's a...
Oh no!
Ah!
Oh, I like the shotgun actually.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Ow!
The Danmaku.
It's okay.
I played Touhou.
Sometimes.
Oh no.
This is already so fun.
Right click?
Wait, what's the difference?
Maybe normal mode is too easy.
Ow!
I said that and then I died.
Oh my god, the achievement is I died.
Thank you forever.
My score is 2?
That's it?
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
Oh, I have to get these.
Yubi yubi!
Oh, the guys come out of there.
I understand now.
I was gonna explode.
Yubi!
I almost walked right into that guy.
Oh, this way.
It's okay.
Again, I play Touhou.
Oh, bonk!
This one feels like you gotta get kinda close on them though, right?
Oh!
Pro Mint Gaming.
Obviously.
This way.
Shut the gun!
The bonk is kinda dangerous.
Yeah, because you have to get so close.
Collect five Korone boxes.
Okay, hold on.
I don't wanna go through stuff so fast, but I also wanna see the other stages and stuff.
Right?
Hmm.
Crazy.
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
One hit KO.
This one looks cute too.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
Oh!
Get out of my way.
Yubi yubi!
Yubi yubi everybody!
Everybody!
Oh my god!
I'm stuck!
Bonk!
Not the bonk.
Also the bonk?
You can't just endlessly shoot.
Sunshine, amigos!
This way?
Thank you, forever.
What?
I used the bonk, you guys all saw.
Let's go sunshine, amigos!
Sunshine!
Sunshine, amigos!
Yubi revolver!
My favorite.
Wait, I wanna use it a little bit.
Where's the...
Ah!
It bounces!
Wait.
Six shots.
I don't wanna change it.
This can't...
Scary!
Shotgun!
Reach out, reach out.
Yes!
Also, you can't go in the water.
Shotgun!
There we go.
Ayayayayayay!
Back off!
No
bonk!
How's everybody doing?
This weekend...
Oh my gosh.
No bonk.
Yubi yubi!
Pretty good.
Wow!
Oh my god.
The revolver's powerful, you guys!
Hahaha!
Right.
I think the revolver is kinda the best.
No, no bonk!
No bonk!
Yubi yubi!
Six shots.
Grocery shopping.
That's always important to do on the weekends, right?
X potato.
Oh!
I unlocked the X...
Another working Sunday.
Happy to listen.
Oh, good luck!
Maybe this is like a harder game to listen to.
It's kinda noisy, right?
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
I like this stage.
Wow wow wow!
Machine gun!
Woah!
It's shaky!
Ohohohohoho!
What's the difference between right click...
and left click?
Yubi yubi!
Woah woah woah!
Indeed.
The button.
One is right, the other is not.
Hi!
You're so right.
I don't wanna get rid of my yubi revolver.
Let's go!
I know the shotgun is so powerful, but like...
The revolver is so awesome.
Nice suit.
Machine gun!
Yubi yubi!
Yubi?
Yubi.
Everybody.
Yubi yubi!
Oh yeah!
Shoot everywhere, miss everything.
Got
it.
Thank you, Huweiba.
Got it.
Okay, let's try the next stage.
The orange box.
Yubi yubi.
Just don't get hit.
Give up your yubis for sacrifice?
You can't even see my yubis!
They're hidden.
They're hidden, my yubis.
Let's go sunshine, amigos!
Let's go
sunshine, amigos!
Wait, this map is kinda whack.
Wait, I don't wanna get the box before I...
Wait,
I don't wanna get the box before I...
Yubi yubi!
Seems kind of a waste to...
To get rid of it.
I'm so good!
Did she just scream?
Oh my god, no!
I don't like the road!
I don't wanna get hit!
Take my yubi.
Wait, who else is shooting?
Oh, those are me.
Bonk, bonk!
Oh no, no bonk, no bonk.
Bonk too difficult, bonk too difficult!
Bonk too hard!
Oh, this way.
It is this way.
Run away, run away, run away!
This way.
Okay, this stage is so... tricky!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Yubi yubi yubi.
Oh my god, it's pushing me away!
Woah, woah, woah!
I'm gonna shot the gun.
This way.
Oh my god.
Yubi yubi!
Yubi yubi yubi!
This one is kind of noisy though.
Ah!
No, no, no, no!
I think we are good.
Wait, this way?
How do I get there?
Oh yeah, yeah!
Ow!
This way!
No!
No bonk, no bonk!
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no!
You have to get so close!
Please!
I think I have to go this way.
Meow!
Oh, here we go.
Yubi yubi!
Joshi!
Oh my god.
Oh no, no, no!
Confidence!
There's even bosses!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much!
You can parry bullets?
You can?
No confidence.
Have confidence.
It's crazy because I did the best on this round.
Even though the stage was so crazy.
The map is so crazy.
Oh, my contact is...
Let's go Sunshine, amigos!
If only I had gotten the X-Potato Cannon again.
Oh!
Maybe it's kind of hard to use too.
Nice!
Oh!
I think I am cheating the system.
What do I have right now?
Oh, down here.
Oh
my gosh, that was so close.
Owie!
I think I got...
Yeah, I'm stuck.
I'm gonna keep shooting.
There we go.
Oh, here it is.
Yubi yubi!
Am I
hitting anything?
Nothing.
I'm hitting everything and nothing at the same time.
Yubi yubi!
Yubi!
No, no, no!
When she laughs, it's so funny.
He's got his back.
Where's the box?
That's a good question.
He came from nowhere.
Spray and pray.
No, he came from nowhere!
No!
Okay.
Let's go sunshine, amigos!
I feel so much more energy when she says...
When she says amigos.
Actually, I think I prefer shooting in like the...
Oh, this way.
Shooting in like the one...
direction than both.
Using the finger guns like this.
Woah, woah, woah!
Here we go!
Wait, I wanna test it.
Oh, you can!
Kind of...
You can shoot the...
bullets fast.
It's not...
Oh my god, the roaches are so fast.
Oops.
But you do have to be pretty close.
And it's also only...
It's directional, so it's...
a little tricky in that regard.
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
Nice!
Uh, this way.
I hear them coming out.
Goodbye, little roach.
Oh my gosh!
X Potato Cannon is OP!
I don't wanna get rid of it!
It's so awesome!
Uh, this way.
Where is she?
Nice!
I think I killed some...
body.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Sorry!
I'm sorry!
She literally took a...
Took a...
A cannon to the face.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Launched into orbit.
Fuck!
Does it work for these?
Oh, it does!
But it's...
They're slow.
It's tricky.
Okay.
Oh, I need to go this way?
Where is it?
Oh!
The three husketeers?
Wait, where are they?
Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
I got knocked by dog.
I got... I got...
Listener-san needs to chill.
For real.
Chainsaw!
Glad you're enjoying your Helldivers training.
I didn't even get to...
Shoot the... I didn't even get to see the boss at all.
Camigo, let's go!
This one... This stage is tricky.
But I think I like it.
Nice!
I like the challenge.
Whoa!
Cute bastard!
Thank you for the 50!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Wait, hold on.
What's going on?
Oh!
Making sure I don't have a phone call.
Oh.
No, we're good.
Okay.
My phone was like going crazy for some reason.
It was like, you're streaming!
You're supposed to be streaming!
Dang!
Is it on camera?
If you can use it correctly...
It's pretty good, actually.
It's actually pretty good.
That one...
didn't count.
I don't like the roach.
I'm a dog!
Also, please don't send me super chats about my taxes.
Thank you.
I think that's...
Oh!
Okay.
She said have confidence, you guys.
We got this.
Now I'm very confident with my...
weapon.
Oh no!
At least there's no...
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
At least there's no back splash.
Yubi yubi!
No confidence, you guys.
No confidence!
It's the...
roaches.
Oh gosh.
Let's get her.
Let's get her now.
Maybe we got her.
I don't know.
There we go.
Okay.
This way.
How am I making so many?
Okay.
Let's choose...
Let's go back to this one.
I like the pepper box.
Hard mode.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
How hard can it be?
Bonk!
How hard can it be, you guys?
I haven't been able to do a single boss.
But how hard can it be?
Bonk!
Machine gun!
The thing
about this game makes me wanna like...
Oh my gosh.
It makes me want to like...
Conserve bullets.
Even though I know that's not a thing.
You know what I mean?
Oh!
We got him!
She's back!
Shiba!
Nice.
Where is it?
Oh, this way.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I think hard mode is kind of in...
It's actual Touhou now.
Wait!
Oh my god.
Actual Touhou now!
No!
Oh my god.
The machine gun sucks.
It pushes you into all the...
Into everything.
It pushes you into everything.
No!
Go away!
Go away.
Oh no.
Oh no!
No!
Ah!
I got my same scores before.
This is Touhou.
My one contact is so...
Making my eyes so dry.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I think we're good.
We tried.
We get to try the chainsaw.
I'm done.
I don't think the chainsaw is the weapon for me, everybody.
Let's go, amigo.
Let's go!
Still go!
I don't think the chainsaw...
I'm done.
Thank you forever.
Or maybe any weapon.
Maybe I'm skill issue.
Skill issue something something.
Fuck!
Get good and something something.
Wait, am I on hard mode again or am I...
Okay.
Actually, I don't remember.
Did it...
No!
Chainsaw!
I don't like chainsaw!
Oh the... What's it called for that is?
The splash damage is good.
But the reload time is not good.
Skill issue.
Let's go, amigo.
I
got no confidence.
Game over without collecting a single Korone box.
Let's go.
He spawn camped me.
Real.
He spawn camped me in real.
Where did that dog go?
I don't like the chainsaw!
Get me out of here!
No buck either!
Game over!
Roach invasion!
Mint is back!
I'm so happy!
Thanks for the super chat!
Thank you!
Get
away from me, Roach!
Get away from me, Roach!
I had everything!
I had nothing!
We
beat my last score!
Josie!
Those guys were coming up on me so fast!
I can't even see the bosses!
I am playing it on hard mode.
Okay.
Normal mode.
Let's go sunshine, amigo!
I gotta build up my...
My power level.
I wish there was an in-between though.
I feel like maybe...
the normal mode...
Not that it's so easy.
I think I'm just making silly mistakes.
You know what I mean?
This way?
There we go.
Okay.
This way.
Oh.
Egg crystal potato!
Go mint!
Thank you!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
So many roaches!
Egg crystal potato!
I
felt like a little bit like a homing...
I felt like a little bit like a homing...
Like a homing...
Danmaku.
Chiba!
I'm not good at the...
Oh my gosh.
Why does this feel more difficult than the hard mode?
Okay.
Bonk!
No bonk!
Not good at the directional with the...
Bonk hammer.
Yubi yubi!
We're already here!
Where is he?
Ow!
Oh there he is!
I'm die!
Please, I just want to fight the boars.
What a way to die.
It was so stupid.
It was actually so dumb.
Let's go!
It was actually so stupid.
I don't like the machine gun.
Because it pushes you into other...
To other Damakus.
There we go.
Yeah, get his butt.
Get that guy's butt.
Yeah, get his butt!
Get his butt!
But I'm trying to go this way.
Oh!
I'm die!
Thank you forever.
I...
You're such a pro gamer Vtuber.
Thanks.
My high score?
11.
What's your high score?
200.
Pro gamer?
Nice score!
11 high score.
You know what?
I'm just a huge Stranger Things fan.
You know?
Yubi yubi!
Can't really blame me for that.
It's just, you know...
I'm just keeping up with the...
Cool Stranger Things lore...
You know...
Hey, good spageto!
Go shirt!
Thank you so much for the 50!
Oh.
I shouldn't waste these.
Oh gosh, I shouldn't waste these.
Bye dog.
Yubi yubi!
Oh my god, not the roaches please.
Not the roaches!
Why are they so fast?
Also wait, does this cut through?
Oh it does!
That's kinda nice.
Doesn't help if...
If uh...
They're coming from behind.
But...
I don't know what my favorite weapon is yet.
Oh.
Oh wait, should that...
Hand
mine?
Wait, how many more...
Weapons do we have?
I was so close to getting the boss again.
Yubi yubi yubi!
Let's go!
Chainsaw!
Nice to meet you!
Hopped in to say hi.
Hello!
Thanks for dropping by.
Oh there's still quite a lot actually that we haven't unlocked.
Let's go.
Let's go!
Back to this one actually.
Let's try the...
Have confidence!
Have confidence she said.
Bonk!
Oh!
Egg soup potato!
Bonk!
Wait is it this way?
Nope.
Have a confidence everybody!
Shoot nothing!
Hit everything!
I always lose when it's the chainsaw!
Oh gosh please!
Please!
I'll take the bonk!
Just gotta
get through here.
Here we go!
Oh I still don't...
I don't know how this one works.
Wait I'm just gonna leave it.
Wait what do I...
Oh!
That
dog's gonna come here eventually.
Wait
actually...
Sometimes it's just bad RNG.
Sometimes...
I don't know what I mean.
Yubi!
Listener sign.
Oh no!
It's a Yubin time.
I love the...
Oh it's the ping.
Yeah it's the ping.
Something something playing through OBS.
Not really.
That's my favorite opener.
Where's the box?
Oh all the way down there?
It's
always these guys.
They rush you!
They actually rush!
They come in...
Full of confidence.
Oh no!
No no no no no!
No no no!
I'm gonna die.
I'm from the chainsaw!
It doesn't seem like it's a bad weapon.
It's just I think I don't...
I don't know how to properly use it so well.
See like...
There it's pretty good.
You don't need to judge with the chainsaw.
That was so unlucky.
It was so fast.
Right out of there.
Yeah the chainsaw killing bullets is really good.
It is really good, yeah.
Are there achievements?
There are steam achievements, yeah.
I've been getting...
I've been getting some of them.
Like collect...
200 Korone boxes.
Stuff like that.
I thought it would kill him in one hit.
I was wrong.
It's okay, they can stay over there.
In their little...
corner.
Get me out of here.
Not the machine gun.
No machine gun.
I don't like the machine gun.
I have to go backwards.
When I use it.
I feel like the machine gun is the worst one.
It's very hard to use.
It's very...
Oh my god, there should...
There should be a leaderboard.
I'd be top.
Mint phantom.
Number one.
UB collector.
Sorry.
Okay.
Save.
Nice!
They
charge when they see you.
They charge when they see you.
Can the bullets like...
Trying to get this dope.
This stage is really hard for the...
Cannon also.
No, I...
Tried to aim up.
There we go.
Are you trying to kill me?
No, I'm trying to go this way.
Please.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
There we go.
Okay, we got...
We're getting rid of...
A few of them at least.
Let's go around.
Okay.
If I can get one more box, we can go against the boss.
Are
you kidding?
It's always the roaches.
It's always...
Oh my gosh.
Guys, you keep jinxing it.
I know.
I'll never get past 11.
Have confidence.
Oh, thank you.
She's so awesome.
She says have confidence.
Get past 11.
All roach bad.
True.
Wait.
Not the hand mine.
Wait, can it...
Oh, it does explode.
Oh, I got the bonk anyway.
Oh my gosh.
Shubha, please.
Got him before he could come for me.
Nice aim.
Thank you.
Okay.
To explain, I was trying to hit like maybe a wall or something to explode as many as possible.
But it just wasn't happening.
Who is sending so many?
You.
Nice.
Of the wall.
Come here, you.
I got
him before it...
I got him before it...
I think she might like the revolver a lot.
No, it's okay.
Explosions from the X potato destroys bullets too, right?
Yes, it seems to be the case.
It seems to be the case.
Revolver is fine.
But it's okay, it's not bad.
It's never really... is there like a...
Is this a dead end?
Oh my gosh.
It is, yeah.
There's not really a good reason to come down here.
Unless I wanna die by roach!
No please!
Oh god!
I don't like the roach!
No roach, no roach!
Oh my gosh, please!
Why does it feel like it picks up so much around 5?
Oh my god, please.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Bonk!
Bonk has too hard... too long of a cooldown, I feel like.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
He's too...
Oh!
Oh, no!
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh!
I was
doing so well, but also getting nothing.
The roaches are so crazy.
Am I getting worse?
Maybe.
Who knows?
That was the most intense gaming I've ever seen.
I don't think I was getting worse.
It was just really hard to get around from there.
I think I was getting bad RNG with some of the weapons.
Because the potato cannon is great, but...
But does not help in this level.
Oh my gosh.
Does not help at all.
Chainsaw!
Chainsaw wow!
Chainsaw wow, wow, wow.
Up here.
Okay, nice.
This way.
Okay.
Yubi yubi yubi yubi.
Atara is going to hear this and she's going to...
You know what?
Good.
Let her hear it.
I'm destroying her precious...
Not even...
The
best pathetic way to die ever...
You did that all to yourself.
I did.
I did, I did.
It's always 11.
I know, I got it hidden.
I got it hidden.
Go, Sunshine, amigo!
Sunshine!
If I
put one down, and then another...
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
So I should just start putting them down everywhere.
Yubi yubi!
Oh, I can shoot now.
I can shoot now.
Chainsaw...
Yubi yubi!
Bunk!
Bunk, bunk, bunk!
This way.
Bunk this way!
Bunk...
This way!
Bunk this way!
Yeah!
Hit everything and nothing!
Hit everything and...
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
No,
no, no, no.
Not machine gun.
Please, no.
Please, no!
Not machine gun!
Nice!
Sorry.
I shouldn't... I shouldn't...
Maybe...
Are you kidding me?!
Um...
I'm done.
Thank you for...
There's no way!
There's no way I could have fought the boss with...
With the hand mines!
There's no way!
That RNG was so bad.
Worst weapon for the boss.
That was so bad.
We got there so quickly too.
Ghost!
Bunk!
Sorry, man.
It's okay.
I'm having fun.
Oh, this way.
That's part of the game, you know?
Is you just...
Try and try and try and try and try again.
It's one of those fast-paced games, you know?
Wait.
Oh, it's this way.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no!
Nice.
Okay.
That was close.
That was a close one.
It can kind of help launch you where you need to go.
But also, it's not...
Not easy.
Oh, shoot.
We're so close.
It's very addicting for sure.
Quick reset is a lot of fun.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I have...
The curse is broken.
You didn't get 11 this time.
Let's go, Sunshine!
Amigo!
Sunshine!
Yeah, we got...
We got worse!
We didn't get 11.
Listener sign.
Putting you out of your misery.
We're gonna...
Oh my gosh.
Shotgun.
Yubi yubi!
Uh
oh.
Uh oh.
Oh my god.
I got hit too.
Nice!
Not nice.
I need to go.
I'm learning more how to control this.
I'm learning more how to control it...
I think.
Shotgun!
I...
Shit!
Ah!
I am so sorry!
Shuba sniped.
No confidence, no confidence.
We're never gonna beat a boss.
We will!
The stream will end until we beat a boss.
Actually, I am gonna switch to...
We gotta unlock a new weapon.
Let's switch to this place.
I think this one is easier for the cannon.
Sometimes, I'll be honest, the arrow pointing towards the next box makes me feel like that's where I'm pointing at.
So if you see me making a mistake like that, that's exactly what I'm thinking.
I'm looking at the arrow as if it's where I'm pointing my weapon.
Because my brain is silly.
Maybe this map isn't as good.
Maybe this map is really difficult.
Eleven seems to be your lucky number.
Thank you.
Thank you for the eleven eleven.
Oh my god.
Everyone play the lottery.
Play the lottery.
Use eleven.
This isn't fair.
Okay,
I won.
This is my luck.
Ah, this is my luck.
Don't be fooled.
Playing at the top is kinda tough.
No,
I'm not sure I am.
I'm just celebrating 10 years of being a youtuber.
I think I'm gonna win.
So?
I don't know.
But it's hard to say.
I'm sure I will win.
I did not shoot.
Listener-san, please.
Why would you treat your Oshii like this?
They know I'm a phony.
Maybe this one is actually more difficult because it's a little bit more open!
Open!
Hug
me!
Hug me!
Get out of my way!
Power, please!
Okay.
Not exactly what I was thinking, but...
This will maybe do the trick.
Oh, I don't think I got it.
Why are you so fast?
Just circle!
Could be worse.
Could be way worse.
The dogs just run through...
Oh my god.
The dogs just run through the chainsaw.
It's crazy.
I'm so concentrated right now, you guys.
You have no idea.
Why?
Why bonk?
Okay, where's the... where's the...
Where's the guy?
Oh, you think he's down here?
This is not easy.
And we hide behind the trees.
Wait, I can also bonk these back, right?
Ah!
I should've bonked them... bonked the back.
At least you can deflect the bullets, or not.
Let's go!
Yeah.
Come on, Korone.
We got this.
She's like, I've got this.
You!
On the other hand...
That is questionable.
Whether you've got this or...
Oh, nice.
Get... get mined.
Oh god.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
I didn't see you there.
Shotgun.
Next one down here.
Where?
Here?
Nice!
Done!
I like the hand mine, actually.
It has a slow...
It has a slow recharge, but I like being able to control it, too.
Let's go, sunshine amigo.
I got a frisbee!
Let's go, amigo!
Wait, we unlocked something else!
Wait.
Yubi yubi!
Let's see if we get it.
Frisbee, frisbee.
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Yubi yubi!
Nice!
Oh, she says janken because it's the hand.
It's cute.
That saved me.
That saved me for real!
I like that the mines also stay.
They stay, too, which is nice.
So I can set them up everywhere and then...
Nice!
Bonk, bonk!
Wait!
Joshi!
Oh, oh!
Yeah!
Okay, we also can do those.
Maybe if I just loop these.
Okay, nice.
Good job, guys!
Frisbee!
We did it!
No!
You can die by the frisbee.
That's how I died.
I got an achievement called get hit by the frisbee.
A
bone meringue.
The frisbee sucks.
You can also right click to reflect it.
Oh!
Still congratulations, man.
Thank you.
Yippee!
Thank you for the five.
Get the ducky.
Thank you!
I was sending them out like crazy, too.
Okay, though.
That's not fair.
If you can't get hit by the revolver's bullets...
I'm stuck!
You shouldn't be able to get hit by the frisbee, either.
Oh, my God.
Not already.
Get out of my face.
Look at that!
Wow, wow, wow!
Wow, wow, wow.
I want to try the frisbee.
Oh, my God.
This is just...
But I do want to try it, also.
Think I got them this time.
Okay.
That was close.
That was a close one.
Please!
They're so aggressive!
They're so aggressive.
Ah, my aim.
I'm hoping... I'm like... spraying a little bit and praying that the splash damage gets them.
Oh my god.
I'm just... I'm just placing them down.
For Josie.
Okay.
This is the guy we did before.
Go away, roaches!
Go away!
Wait, if I just do this...
Oh my gosh.
If I just do this, it's not so bad, right?
Actually.
It's actually kind of awesome.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Do I get it back or...
So
close.
Starting to believe.
Right click for three at once.
Oh!
I keep forgetting to right click on these weapons.
Like I do it on this one because it... Instead of like doing the side by side, you do the one direction.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
I'll take a bonk.
Recharge.
So I'm not sure how...
I see.
What if I right click on this one?
Is it the same?
I can't tell actually.
I inhaled so fast that I choked on my spit.
Don't die.
I'm already dead.
Dang.
These are all like right next to each other.
We're already at six.
I don't even need to...
Machine
gun.
Machine gun.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Oh
my god.
No, Shuba.
Please.
Shuba.
How am I supposed to beat him with the hammer?
Lure him.
I didn't even get a single hit on it.
Oh, there.
Let's go sunshine, amigo.
Sunshine.
Back to eleven.
Eleven curse.
This game is tricky though.
It's fun but...
Also me bad.
But that's okay.
I like
the hand mine.
It's just not good if we're...
Stuffed quick.
Or for...
Yeah.
Situations where you need to be firing a lot and fast.
Wait.
Oh, it's this way.
Why am I going?
Why am I going down?
Stop.
Okay.
Die.
Please.
Please bounce.
Die.
Listener-san, so small and so easy to miss.
Where is it?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
What the?
What is this?
Pinky pledge.
The terror.
I don't like bugs.
I hate that one so much.
Yeah.
I didn't know what that one did.
So I was just running to see if...
Okay.
That's okay.
It's like racing spell card.
I'm a dog.
Not the actual Touhou.
Yumi.
I haven't played Imperishable Night.
I don't even know.
Actually, I'll be honest.
I probably have played Imperishable Night the least.
This wasn't one of my favorites.
Which is okay.
I don't know what the...
It's hard to say or it's hard for me to figure out what the...
Oh my god.
How big the splash damage is on the mines.
Bunk.
There we go.
Take that guy out real fast.
Shoot the gun.
Imperishable Night is peak.
It's good.
It's just not one of my favorites.
I played Mountain of Faith.
Must.
And Hello?
Hello?
Hello.
Imperishable Night.
And...
Oh no, no.
Oh my god.
How did I live?
How am I alive?
There was one other one.
I played UFO quite a bit.
Let's go sunshine, Amigo.
Sunshine.
And...
USD, obviously.
No frisbee.
Oh god, I'm scared of the frisbee.
I'm scared of the frisbee.
It's gonna get me.
There's one that I'm... cannot...
I don't know why I can't think of which one.
My brain is only consumed by Yubi.
I'm Yubi-brained right now.
There's a potato.
Tango.
The overkill.
You know what?
It's not overkill.
These guys are annoying.
These guys, these tiny little guys...
are pain in my side.
Pain in my side.
Oh my god.
Hello?
No, Shuba.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shuba, no!
I just hear her go Shuba, Shuba, Shuba.
Trying to take some of these other guys out.
Oh my god.
Shuba, Shuba, Shuba.
Maybe in like here.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Take him out.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Help me!
Oh my god.
That was a close one.
I'm in danger.
I'm in danger, you guys.
Help me.
Help.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Screw you!
Little roach.
Sorry dog.
Oh my god, that did not kill dog.
That did not finish off the dog.
Well, let Shuba do her thing over there.
Where is... Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many people!
Please, I'm an introvert!
I don't want to talk to anyone!
Okay, okay, okay.
Too real.
I
only count up to 14, you guys.
This is intense.
I don't think... You know what?
I intended on this being a short stream anyway.
Because I just wanted to, you know, hang out a little bit today.
But I don't think I can physically handle the amount of stress this game gives me.
For so long.
Keep
playing.
Thank you for the 50.
Thank you.
No, we're still gonna go.
I'm not done yet.
I'm having fun.
It's just terrifying.
It's a fun terrifying.
Right?
I'm scared.
And also...
Like these guys.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Shubaaaaaa!
There it is.
I
ran right into it.
Why?
Why am I so bad in this game?
I'm scared.
No confidence.
I saw someone say they got a score of 30.
I'm half way there, almost.
I'm almost half way there.
Hello?
It's a dog.
That was scary.
This way.
There we go.
I got 30 and I'm like the...
neon cannon.
What's that?
Wait.
I want a cannon.
What's that?
What's it do?
I want that.
This is just definitely something I can see myself like playing and you know.
And like oh I have a... well I was gonna say when I have a free extra couple of minutes.
That's quite rare.
But uh...
Frisbee please.
Frisbee.
It'd be fun if the...
if the dog chased after the frisbee.
Can you move?
No!
I need to get to the box!
Where is it?
Stop chasing after my...
Why are you so obsessed with me?
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Defense!
That was absolutely 100% me.
That was 100% me being greedy.
What's wrong with me?
Why did I do that?
That was me being greedy.
My greed.
Don't be greedy.
Oh my gosh Mei Ling told me.
Okay I'm gonna pretend you guys aren't here.
Okay sorry.
I'm gonna pretend you guys...
don't even exist.
Concentration.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see it!
Dang it.
It's okay though.
Forever 19!
Woo!
You're pretty good.
Just blame it on us.
Say you peaked.
Okay.
I missed you guys a little bit.
So I just...
had to make sure you were okay.
You were locked in there for a minute.
There were some parts that I got really lucky.
There were some parts though that I got really lucky.
That I shouldn't have won I think.
Nice focus run.
Thank you!
Thank you.
See?
If I pretend I'm not streaming.
It's a little...
See I can do alright.
I can do a little bit better.
See performance anxiety is a real thing.
It was great watching your faces.
You got certain weapons ready.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
My left contact.
I mean my right contact.
Ah!
It's so...
It's acting up so weird today.
I don't know what's up with it.
We haven't done the first stage in a while.
I will go back to it after this round.
Though I do think this is my favorite.
It's not the easiest.
But I like it.
You can hang out too!
Chainsaw!
Hello?
Fuck!
That was good timing.
No I don't wear glasses.
Ever.
I absolutely...
hate...
glasses on me.
Especially because...
wearing them with the...
headset...
digs into my ears and gives me really bad...
headaches.
So...
I don't...
wear them.
Oh that was fast.
Oh!
I...
I shot myself into the dog.
Yeah.
I started wearing earbuds for that reason.
Makes sense.
Right?
I like the look of them but they are so annoying to wear.
Right!
Yeah I like the look of them.
Well actually I don't really particularly like...
how they look on me.
I like how they look on other people.
Chainsaw!
Or maybe that...
Oh wait sorry I forgot to go to the other stage.
Maybe that's just me.
Um...
Like... What's the word?
Trying to make it so I don't like them.
So that I don't want to wear them.
You know what I mean?
Oh that was up.
Why am I so silly?
Bye bye!
Get out of here.
Oh!
That was...
Oh my gosh.
That was so stupid...
lucky.
Shiba!
Okay I can leave.
Oops.
Oops!
Bank!
No first base.
Okay.
Maybe...
Oh not the worst for...
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh my
god.
Not the roaches.
Please not the roaches.
Not the roaches!
Go away!
I can't get the roaches.
Where are they?
Where's the pinky monster?
Let's go!
There.
There we go.
Man.
I jinxed it.
She's getting good.
Stop!
What do you mean?
Yeah you did jinx it though.
It's always... Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Oh god.
My contacts.
It's like... I think it's just dry.
I'm a dog!
Oops I forgot to change those.
It's because I'm not blinking.
Why did I almost...
Walk into that guy like I thought he was a box?
That would have been crazy.
If I just walked into that guy like I thought he was a box...
Whoa!
Keep placing them around...
Um...
Where they spawn.
Hydration check.
Yes!
I will hydrate!
Yuppie!
Oh.
Joshi again.
That's okay.
Because we were gonna do this anyway.
Bread box!
I hear him.
Where are you?
It's weird not being used to this...
Stage!
Oh my god.
Please.
I have an itch.
Don't... don't spawn.
Okay.
Thank you.
That also requires me to...
Oh my god.
Be...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa!
There's so many people!
An extrovert.
Is what I was trying to say.
Did you hear that?
The box is...
Oh my god.
Why does this stage feel the most crowded as possible?
And those guys are so fast.
Let's go!
Pinkie again!
Oh.
Oh my god.
That was...
How am I alive?
Actually, I have no idea how I'm alive right now.
I should have died.
What is my hitbox anyway?
What even is my hitbox?
How did I hit it?
Very tiny.
It clearly is very tiny.
If I press shift, will I see it?
That wasn't maybe the best weapon.
Well, it was good, but also...
Let's go, amigo!
Let's go!
Not so...
Easy for me.
I hate frisbees.
No frisbee.
Yeah, it's not great for bosses.
Yeah, that's for sure.
It's because it's weak.
It's hard to find them.
Oh.
Oh, this way.
Also, I'm not familiar with this map.
Where is the box?
This is... what?
Leave me alone.
Oh my gosh.
Am
I able to bomb?
This
way.
Really?
I don't want to fight the boss with the mine, though.
No confidence.
Ugh!
What if we get to the bo...
What if we get to the boss on hard?
Oh, wait.
We did.
Okay, we can do it again.
We can do it again.
I believe.
I don't believe.
My gosh, girls.
You came running up on me.
I was like, why are there so many people already?
It's
a lack of confidence thing, everybody.
It's a confidence thing, everybody.
I forgot we were on hard mode.
Oh, wow.
They shoot so many more, too.
I just realized.
I think everyone's faster.
And also...
They shoot more.
Yeah, this guy shoots way more.
Oh, wait.
What did I hit?
I actually didn't notice at all.
Thank you for the five.
Thank you.
What did I hit?
Revolver.
It was a fast bullet.
It was a bullet.
Okay.
Wow.
I'm regressing?
Let's go, amigo.
For real.
Once
again, the revolver seems to be a winner.
The revolver seems to be a real winner in this game.
I think it's actually super good.
Okay.
I know this is going to sound like Cope.
But I pressed D and I didn't...
Wait.
I know this is going to sound like Cope.
But it was actually my keyboard.
No, it sounds like Cope, for real!
But it was actually my keyboard!
Sure...
No, it was!
It was!
It sounds like Cope!
But I... you know...
You guys know that I'm the first to admit when I'm actually bad at something.
You guys know I wouldn't cope like that!
You guys know!
This way...
Machine gun!
No machine gun.
Oh, good.
Indeed!
It's Josie again.
Those guys are really fast.
These ones, these ones.
I have to watch out for those.
Where is he?
Oh my god!
Thank you, Arzy!
Oh...
Sounds...
Like rhymes with hope.
I've only known you for a week or two, Mint.
So, Cope...
You know what?
That's so fair.
Wow!
Me now, because it's the boss, you guys.
Eleven is the boss!
Alright.
Let's go, amigo.
Let's go!
One more try.
Last... LG, LG everybody.
LG, LG.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, no.
Hold on.
LG one more time.
It's because... like I know I ran into it.
I forget that the chainsaw also pushes you.
Just like how the machine gun does.
LG, round three!
When I say LG, I mean...
One more try getting to the boss.
Oh my god, already?
Why
am I not shooting?
What's wrong with me?
Maybe I'm already checked out.
Maybe I'm like, you know what?
I'm done with this game.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
My roach trauma.
Wait, actually?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, is this way?
Okay, that's new.
Okay, that's...
Um...
I didn't know.
Did it ever do that?
No, it didn't.
That's hard mode, baby.
TV table turn.
I'm sorry.
I feel like I've just been screaming this whole time.
You know what?
Maybe we'll call it here.
Give my... give my throat a rest.
No!
No, I don't feel satisfied.
I won't feel satisfied.
Try to walk!
Never mind.
LG.
LG again.
I wish I could just have the revolver the whole time.
Machine
gun.
Machine gun.
Shooting
backwards!
Oh, this way.
Oh, my God.
They're all here.
Go away!
Okay.
Bonk!
If I lose to this little listener's hand, I might actually become the Joker!
I
was moving up and I was too slow.
I don't know.
It's hard.
No, no, no.
It was if I died to the little guy, but I was fine.
Instead, I... I was moving up, but the...
I don't know.
I don't... I don't know...
What?
I mean, I guess, obviously, you hit my hitbox, but...
Hmm.
This stream could have its own Scream compilation.
I'm the Joker.
Then keep going.
All it takes is one bad day.
Did you guys see the trailer for the next Joker movie?
The one with, uh...
Hold on, I'm fixing my context again.
Oh, my eye hurts so bad.
Um...
With, uh...
Yeah, with Harley Quinn!
Lady Gaga, Harley Quinn!
I usually avoid trailers.
That's... that makes... that's...
No, I... I get that.
I get that.
Yeah.
Oh, it's out!
Oh, wait!
Wait, is it actually out?
The Frisbee Killing You is a reference to the original...
game Super Crate Box...
that this game plays homage to from 2010.
Where the disc gun could bounce back and kill you.
Ah!
That makes sense.
Joker 2 with Joaquin and...
Lady Gaga.
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
We live in a musical.
Yeah, Lady Gaga is...
playing Harley Quinn.
It actually looks so good.
Oh, it isn't out until October.
Who said that they saw it?
Everyone knows it's only LG if it's a good round.
Andragos, thanks for the time!
Gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Don't care for the casting.
It's...
I think it's...
Hold on.
different, yes.
I think it's...
Like I wouldn't expect Harley Quinn to be Lady Gaga.
But I don't think I mind it so much either.
Me when I spread misinformation.
I'm spreading misinformation on the internet!
That's me when I spread misinformation.
I think I'll still see it though.
I really like the first one.
Lady Gaga was great in American Horror Story, so I'll reserve judgement.
I think...
I tend to like Lady Gaga a lot.
Because...
People tend to underestimate her.
Like...
Back in the day, before she was like...
Not back in the day.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Like...
When she was still like...
Poker face kind of Lady Gaga.
Like people, you know...
Just thought she was some generic pop star like singer.
And that her singing was, you know...
Average.
But...
I can't believe Shrek came out 27 years ago.
No it didn't.
When did Shrek come out?
Actually I have no idea.
One shouldn't forget that overconfidence is a slow and insidious killer.
Stop calling me out.
I saved the streamlabs.
Sorry that I haven't been reading them out.
I see them though.
Have confidence, Minto-chan.
Minto-chan kawaii.
Totally real.
Undoctored.
Coronate.
Quote.
But yeah.
When she was...
When Lady Gaga was still like...
Poker face lady.
People didn't know that she could sing.
But she can sing so well, actually.
Let's go, amigo.
Let's go.
She's...
Shrek?
No!
She's good.
Yobi!
Wait.
Oh, I'm on hard mode again.
I forgot.
No, Frisbee!
Yobi!
Scared of Frisbee.
Don't do that,
mister.
Don't do that, mister.
Oh, this side.
Roach!
This game has proven to me that my throat is never going to recover.
I'm always going to be raspy for the rest of my life.
I think I'm always going to sound raspy for the rest of my life.
Every time she says that, it makes me think, kurae yo, which is, you know, like, it reminds me of Free Rin being in the Mimic Mouth.
Oh, I haven't gotten this in a while.
Oh my gosh.
Overkill, but that's okay.
Yobi, Yobi!
Kurae yo!
Kuae yo!
That's me in this game.
I'm scared.
Does it sound like...
Punk!
Shut the gah!
Okay, here we go.
What weapon are we going to get for the boss?
Oh my god.
Don't jinx it.
Don't jinx it!
Oh, I'm dying.
Thank you, boy.
And that was...
Let's go, Amigo!
Let's go!
That was your classic jinx, everybody.
That was like the most classic jinx ever.
I'm dying.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
Thank you!
Thank you, Chiron-chan!
Oops.
It was down here anyway.
Oh my god, please.
I'm getting...
I was getting cornered.
I'm getting cornered.
Her duets with Bennett really showed her talent.
Who's Bennett?
What's this way?
Run!
This way.
Please.
I'm regressing.
Who's Tony Bennett?
The singer.
What has he...
Um...
What has he done?
Okay, this is actual LG.
LG!
Nice.
LG, everybody.
Oh my god.
Unless I get eaten by the roaches.
I don't know.
Where have you been, Shuba?
You were gone.
And then you came back.
And now...
Bunk!
Bunk, bunk, bunk!
No Frisbee!
No Frisbee.
Go away, Frisbee.
Guys, I think I'm dead.
I think I'm dead.
Or not!
Oh my god.
How I lived that?
I don't know.
I don't know how I lived that.
God gamer.
Don't clip any of my failures of just running into, you know, normal guy.
Clip that one.
Clip me being a god gamer, okay?
Oh!
You know what?
That's okay.
Don't clip that part.
Because I'm running into a small guy.
I didn't think it was possible for ghosts to be possessed, but...
I think I was possessed by ninja.
Terrible.
Oh, don't clip!
This is not here!
No, no, no, no!
Don't, don't, don't do it.
Don't clip this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Actually, hold on.
Let's see.
Okay, hold on.
Now we just need it in...
Put it in black, and I gotta find a font that's kinda similar.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
I know I have some.
Quick, someone contact the devs and ask them what font they use.
I'll download it.
Do I not have an 8-bit-y kind of font?
Oh,
I thought I had some.
I know I used to have some.
Maybe I have to re-download them.
The one looks sus.
Are you sure?
I'm hacking.
I'm hacking... the game right now.
Quack, quack, quack, quack...
What's that one?
I don't remember ever downloading that.
What is this one?
Oh no, it's gone!
Oh my god!
I think I messed up.
Oh wait.
It's so thin.
She's such a skilled gamer.
You guys, I'm gonna have to ask you to avert your eyes.
I'm not trying to give away my gaming secrets here right now, okay?
I'm just saying.
Okay?
What do you mean by that, Ghostorb?
What do you mean by that?
God gamer.
Literally just screencap and crop?
You're so right!
Oh my gosh!
Why
did I think of that?
Drumroll please!
No!
I promise you, Dev.
I got 19!
I got 19.
That's my... I promise.
Right chat?
You can vouch for me.
You saw that.
Right chat?
I'm grabbing you by the neck.
I'm grabbing you by your collar right now.
If you don't say that I didn't get 19, you better say that I got 19 right now.
You better say that I got 19 right now.
Is that the IQ?
You better say it.
You got 19 and it was a really good run.
You better say that.
It's true.
I saw 19.
Forever 19.
You got 19.
Thank you.
She's an 11 but she's a ghost.
Harder.
Yeah.
You know what?
I don't think we need a harder level.
I think you're right.
I think I need to be knocked down a peg.
I think I need to only get 5.
You're too high for me.
Can you grab me by the neck again?
No, I grabbed your collar.
Like a bully, you know?
It's true.
I was the 19.
You know what?
It's not about quantity.
It's about quality.
Right?
You don't want to have...
You don't want to have 19...
whatever friends.
You want to have 11 best friends.
You don't want to have 19 friends that you can't rely on.
11 is the perfect number.
Of friends to have.
The 11 best people.
Exactly.
Aim for 11.
Dare I say the consistency to get this score.
I give it an 11 out of 10.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Useless fact.
In the Age of Empires 2 community, 11 is the way people laugh.
Just like W1JP chats.
I've been giggling this whole time.
Okay.
Maybe one day I will come back and have a...
Revengeance with this.
I'll practice off stream.
It is so much fun though.
I had a lot of fun.
11, 11, 11, 11, 11.
What does it mean?
Like why though?
Is it because if you say 11 it's an emo?
Or...
Like a laughing emo?
Revengeance?
Metal Gear?
I'll be honest.
I forget that revengeance is not a real word sometimes.
I've...
I've been like...
I've been saying revengeance unironically.
Like I used to say it ironically and now I say it unironically.
But yeah, Tian, this is such a fun game!
I had so much fun.
And I'm gonna beat my high score.
I'm gonna get to 25.
That's the goal.
And I'm gonna screenshot it.
And it won't be...
It won't be edited because you guys know I don't have the font.
I don't have the font for...
25, damn.
I'm aiming high.
Photoshop doesn't exist, guys.
You guys, I don't have the font for 25.
It's the laughter taunt in chat.
Yes.
That's so funny.
1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
What fantasy mint outfit would you get?
Mage, etc.
This is so much fun!
Thank you for making a fun game.
And it's so cute.
I love hearing Korone say I'm a dog!
If I can...
Fantasy outfit...
I think merchant is kinda cute.
Right?
Like a wanderer...
Wandering trade merchant.
Also...
A mage would be really cute.
Or like a witch.
With a big old witch's hat.
Think...
Think merchant, like Reseteer, right?
Good morning!
What do you buy?
What do you sell?
Alright, I'm gonna move over to...
I don't know if you guys noticed...
But...
I have...
Korone's bones in my hair.
Give me a second...
I'm gonna set up some BGM.
That was good BGM...
But maybe something a little more chill...
To let my brain sleep out of my ears.
Actually, no.
I want this one.
Yeah!
You see him?
I'll move this away for a second.
But it kind of is hard to see...
Because of my own hair clip.
I stole Korone's bones.
Her bones are not mine.
Yubi yubi.
As they say.
Korone was the very first YouTuber I watched regularly.
So it was really cool to see you play this.
There's so many cute little references and everything.
So fun.
Did she take your yubis in return?
I have no yubis.
Look.
Can't see my yubis.
Just floppy.
Under here, they're just nubs.
Just little...
It's like...
Actually, it's like a lego...
Lego hand.
It's a lego hand.
So it's just like...
One big circle.
Send yubis.
Well guys.
I'm going to...
Read donations.
Real quick.
Like I said.
It's a bit of a shorter stream.
Just wanted something to have a bit of fun with.
Like a little crazy amount of fun.
Crazy time with rather.
It was fun though.
It was a lot of fun.
Revengeance.
Middle English period 11...
11...
Wait.
Borrowed from French.
A furious act of revenge.
To use violence to attain peace.
Oh.
Well there you go.
Revengeance is a real word.
Revengeance.
Korone is my oshi.
Thanks for playing this min.
Thank you.
Korone is so cute.
She is so so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Did you guys see the new...
The new...
Kanatan...
Pop-up parade.
That was announced.
Or not announced but went up for pre-order recently.
Oh my gosh.
I keep looking at it on AmiAmi because...
It looks so...
Well made.
It's so...
It's so cute.
I'll be honest.
I don't watch her so much.
But I think her design is like...
One of my favorites ever.
It's just the cutest...
Ever.
It's so...
Such a good design.
Everything about it is so perfect.
I like her mama so much.
Her mama's art is always so nice.
Her scale is crazy good too.
Oh I know.
It has so much like...
The base and everything.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
She has some amazing outfits.
She does.
So cute.
So so cute.
I honestly...
I think I like the pop-up parade more than her...
I'm looking at it right now.
I think I like it more than her...
Than the scale figure.
I think it's maybe...
Because in the scale figure...
She looks a little cooler.
But in the pop-up parade...
She looks cuter.
Maybe.
I don't know.
The pop-up is 10 out of 10.
Sometimes some pop-up parade figures...
Like...
I don't mean this...
Sometimes...
They can get the faces...
Well this happens with figures quite often.
To be honest.
Sometimes the faces can be a little off.
But this one is so perfect.
This one is so good.
Or just get a figure in general.
Be the coolest.
Sometimes the pose is too simple.
I typically like...
Figures with like...
Cool bases.
Or like...
Like there's the Shigure Ui one.
Where she's like sitting in the chair.
So it's not really a base but like...
It just adds a little bit of extra something.
Like I have this one figure...
Where it's just an original character.
But she's coming out of a tablet.
Let me see if I can find a picture of it.
Wait...
What was it called?
Uh...
Oh!
I found it!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go Google.
By Nishizawa.
It's Nishizawa-san.
Is there...
It's like the artist...
What's the word?
Self...
Why can't I ever speak?
It's so cute though.
Hold on, I'll show you.
The figure.
Let me...
I'm gonna crop it a little bit.
Oh no, I don't need to crop it.
Just kidding.
Save.
Nishizawa-san.
And I'll be honest, like...
I like this artist.
I'm not like a die-hard fan.
But I just thought the figure was so cool.
Like look how cool that is!
And like she's coming through the tablet.
It's so awesome.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for...
50!
Please!
You've already given so many today!
It's awesome, right?
It's really cool.
It's really, really cool.
Um...
I don't have...
When I collect figures, it's either something like this.
You know?
Or like a character I super duper love.
But I'll get stuff.
There's one figure that I missed out on.
And uh...
Can I get more?
No!
I appreciate it though.
Thank you.
There was one figure of like a girl.
Oh!
I found the picture.
Oh my gosh.
How am I so good at finding these pictures?
She's in a box.
Like look at this.
I should've ordered it.
I'm such a fool.
Look how cool this looks.
Oh!
I was gonna say she looks like Rei from Evangelion.
Like isn't it so...
It looks so cool!
Like...
I really like unique...
Kind of figures like this.
It looks so cool.
It's not a cardboard box though.
It is not a cardboard box.
No.
And then I ordered one recently.
I don't know when it comes out.
Um...
But uh...
It's a Yuru Camp figure.
It's actually technically two figures.
Because it's both of them.
And look at this.
Look at this.
The base is grass!
I can touch grass!
By touching this figure!
Wait.
Did you gift another 50?
I can't tell.
If you did, thank you.
You did!
Thank you.
Actual...
It's not actual grass.
It's fake real grass.
But it's so cute, right?
She's riding on her little bike.
It's such a cute figure.
So cute.
Yeah.
So...
I have that coming...
When is it released?
In August.
August.
I will not.
And she's drinking corn soup.
In the...
On the figure.
It's just made for me, I think.
It's made for me.
You watched Yuru Camp?
Yes!
Yuru Camp is one of my favorite anime!
Yes, I love Yuru Camp.
Trying to see what else I have ordered.
Well, actually, I don't have that much left.
I think that's the biggest thing I have...
left.
Yes.
The other stuff is like a small free-rin acrylic.
And...
Oh, I got this too!
This is really cute.
And it wasn't so expensive either.
Even though it was...
I think it's that they're really small.
Look how cute!
It's just little busts of the free-rin cast!
It's so cute!
They're like tiny little busts of them.
So cute, so cute.
The trio.
Feminine shambles.
Looks like chess pieces.
I think, to be honest, they might be even that small.
But that's good.
That's okay.
It's good for like a...
I don't know where to put them yet.
I think I...
Oh my gosh!
Oh, stop!
I didn't notice the back!
No, I'm gonna cry...
You guys, look at the back!
No way!
I didn't notice it, but when I ordered it...
What?
That's so cute!
Oh...
It's so...
I'm tearing up.
It's so sweet.
That's so cute.
Figures are so expensive now, you guys.
Figures are so expensive.
Not only just the...
The shipping.
But...
Like...
Scale figures now...
They used to be $150.
Maybe $100.
$100 to $150.
Now they're like $200, $300.
It's crazy!
Ugh...
I remember when they were $80.
They're so expensive now.
It's so...
So insane.
The ones I like are not $300.
Are they more?
Less?
I can't tell what you mean by that.
Include shipping and it goes close to $300.
Luckily... I say this luckily...
Not luckily, but like...
The yen is weak right now, so...
It's the way I justify some things, but...
No...
They're so pricey.
Makes me...
Like...
Um...
Like Pop-Up Parade is kind of a blessing.
With how...
Inexpensive it is.
And the range too.
The variety of characters you can get with Pop-Up Parade.
Makes it so awesome.
But yeah...
Nendoroids used to be $30.
I know!
Nendoroids and Figma's used to be...
So...
Much less expensive too!
I saw a holo figure going for $1.3k.
Okay...
To be fair...
If it's the Pekora one you're talking about...
Um...
I think...
Okay, so I'm pretty sure it's the same brand that does...
These kimono designs.
And it's actual fabric.
From what I understand.
So I get it.
It's actually like...
The quality.
But it is still insane.
And it's also 1 4th scale.
It's 1 4th scale too.
It's not even like 1 7th.
It's huge.
It's really really big.
So...
Yeah...
It's a lot of money.
But...
It is quite big and detailed.
I've seen...
I know because I've seen these...
These designs multiple times.
They pop up pretty often on AmiAmi.
So...
Do you have any 1 4th scales?
No...
I don't know.
I have a bigger Kuroneko from Oreimo.
But I don't know what scale she is.
But she's a little bigger.
But I don't think she's 1 4th.
Or maybe she is.
Maybe she is 1 4th.
Oh she is 1 4th.
What do you know?
She's 1 4th.
So mine is 1 4th.
And she's on her knees.
And this Pekora is standing up.
If that gives you any idea of how big it's going to be.
Like it's going to be really really big.
Yoshitoku does the fabric for the Pekora figure.
They've made doll clothes for over 100 years.
But the mark up between those anime figures.
And the traditional dolls is massively skewed.
That makes sense.
I don't know if it's the same manufacturer.
Or the same...
Like company.
I don't know.
As the other ones.
Let me see.
Pekora!
Yoshitoku... Yoshitoku...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay, the Pekora one is a lot more expensive than, like...
Okay, wait, no, that one's on sale.
Okay, see, here, I'm gonna show you some other examples, ones that I've seen.
Because she's also 1 4th scale, you have... I think it's really just their anime figures, then, if you're saying that the other ones are less...
Like, their actual dolls are less expensive, because I've seen this... this, um...
Maid Dragon one.
Dragon Maid.
Uh, this one is...
Uh, one is... it's... yeah, uh, wait...
Uh, it's... it's 157,000 yen.
So, uh, AmiAmi says it's about a thousand dollars, and that's on sale.
So there's that one...
And, uh, let's see...
I haven't seen this one, but I'm...
Oh, oh, it's so beautiful!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God, it's so beautiful!
Wait, is this also 1 4th?
Oh, yes, it is.
Oh, this one's about the same price as the... as the Pekora one.
Oh, my God!
Look at her!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, no, she's so beautiful!
She's so beautiful!
Ugh!
But, yeah, they do quite a bit of these.
And they are always this pricey, every time I've seen them.
Every time I've seen them, they're this pricey.
I saw the thumbnail and thought you had a collab with Korone.
A lot of people thought!
Time zones make it hard to catch streams, but we'll support you regardless.
Also want to mention you have a nice voice.
Take care from Australia!
Thank you so much!
I'm sorry that the time zones don't line up, but I appreciate you dropping by when you can.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
When are we getting a $1,300 made min figure?
Never.
And there's a Kizuna Ai one, too.
It's really...
Their figures are really, really cute.
It's really beautiful.
This one's also 1-4th scale.
Oh my gosh.
Their figures are just really pretty.
If you go to AmiAmi and search...
Oops.
And search...
Yoshitoku?
Yoshitoku, you'll find them.
Any survey from Good Smile, I'm going to be asking for min.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Figures are so expensive.
These ones I...
I...
I know...
It might be like a weird copium, but I kind of get it.
Just because of the fabric.
You'd think that!
Well, no.
Yeah, because of the fabric and because of the scale.
The size of them.
It is an expensive hobby.
It is.
It's a very expensive hobby.
I think it's also partially why...
Maybe I haven't gotten into so...
Well, not why I haven't gotten into so many anime, but like...
Part of me is just like, if I get into more things...
I'll want to collect more merch from the things.
You know what I mean?
So it's just like...
Like last night...
Right now, Tsurugaya is doing free shipping.
So I was looking at some Metal Gear stuff last night.
And I was like...
Damn, it's sale!
Thank you for the 50k!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
But...
Beware Warhammer then.
I would say that Warhammer is not really my aesthetic.
But...
Well, you know...
I like military aesthetic.
So...
It's not completely far off that I got into Metal Gear.
But yeah, I was on Tsurugaya.
And I was seeing some Blue Archive figures.
And I was like...
Now it's free shipping, but...
The pain...
In the end...
If you're wondering...
I did not get anything.
I did not get any of them.
So...
One fourth scale.
Dang, almost as tall as you!
That's a good one!
Good one, floofy hoots!
So hilarious!
I'm LMAO-ing right now.
I'm LMFAO-ing right now.
I'm ROFL-ing right now.
Funniest joke I've ever heard.
ROFL ROFL ROFL.
I don't feel safe.
ROFL-copter.
Literally ROFL-coptering.
How do I turn?
Help!
Help me!
Hmm.
I have no idea what to write in here.
That was scary...
I don't know what to write in here.
That was freaky.
I don't know what the front page is.
Freaky.
Okay.
I did say I was gonna do donation readings.
So...
Let me...
I'm going to start with Extreme Labs.
I got the tightest laugh treatment.
I'm so happy.
Glad.
I'm glad that I can make that real for you.
I did.
I need to get some water.
Water, water, water.
Today is the 14th.
Starting with...
Wildest Duck.
I think this was before stream.
Thank you!
I hope we can help a little so you can keep having fun, Gamba!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Wildest Duck, thank you again!
Congrats on your collab with Korone.
You must have given her so many yubies.
She's so quiet now.
Can't wait for when she's done with them.
Yeah, she was just kinda You know, you heard her the whole time, right?
You heard her say yubi yubi.
You heard her say shotgun.
Being a Blue Archive fan is painful.
There's too many characters.
I have only a handful of characters that I really like, though.
Just a handful.
And that's typically how I am with a lot of things.
Where if there's a ton of characters or something, or if it's an idol group with a ton of members or something, I'll pick, like, just a few.
Top five?
Top five...
Okay, um...
Hold on, I'm just gonna open up Blue Archive.
I haven't logged in today anyway, so it's good.
Um, definitely Koharu's up there.
Koharu and Cherino are, like, my top two.
I love them so much.
Koharu and Cherino.
Cherino is so...
I love...
She's so funny.
I love her.
I love Koharu.
Because she's, like, she's actually, like, peak character design.
She is... I don't know how they could get so many cute things so perfectly.
Balanced and well in one character.
Just so cute.
I think Cherino is underrated.
But she's super duper cute.
She's so silly.
Mahjong Soul Stream?
I don't even know how to play Mahjong.
Though I did try to learn from Mahjong Soul before.
Okay, let's see.
The screen that popped up is Onsen Cherino for me.
Okay, students.
Um, I also really love Toki.
Um, and Hina.
I love Hina and I love Toki.
Um, wait, so that's Koharu, Hina, Toki, Cherino.
That's four?
Um...
I really like Hoshino, but I wouldn't put her in my top five.
Um, I really like, um...
Uh, I really like Midori and, um...
Oh my gosh, why is her sister's name blanking on me?
What's her sister's name?
Momoi!
Yes, oh my gosh.
I was just like...
Of course, Momoi, Momoi.
I was like, I feel so awful not remembering, or not remembering it because, um...
Because...
Momoi Haruko.
I always think of Momoi Haruko every time I think of Momoi.
Which clearly is not enough.
Um, I also really like Arisu.
I like the whole game dev team, to be honest.
Um, gamer cat twins are the best.
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh, the new twins that were released in JP.
Fuuu...
They're so cute.
Problem solver 68 girls are great.
They are!
They are, they are.
I really like Aru too, but I don't have her.
I really love Aru.
Um...
Making me want to play.
Sorry.
The Blue Archive talk, everybody.
You can ignore if you're not in the Blue Archive.
Uh...
But it's like the only gacha.
Oh!
Shiroko!
Of course!
I have to put in Shiroko because she's voiced by my favorite seiyuu.
Ogura Yui.
She's actual tenshi.
Pyon pyon kyuku dere supremacy.
Peace, peace.
I also love how goofy Shiroko is.
She's so fun.
Because she's...
She's like a kudere, but she's so... so silly.
At the same time.
You're gonna love the dress, Aru.
Yeah.
Thoughts on Wakamo?
I really like Wakamo, but I don't have her.
So I don't know much about her.
Well, I know a little, but you know what I mean.
And um...
I also really like Saki.
I like the rabbit squad a lot because they're really cute.
Um...
Even though I only have Moe.
Um... I only have...
Oh wait, no, I have swimsuit Miyu.
And... oh wait, I have one more too.
Who is it?
Um...
Wait, do I?
Moe...
Oh, Miyako!
Swimsuit Miyako.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mmm.
I got Wakamo swimsuit, but not regular Wakamo.
I don't have either.
I don't have that many characters, to be honest.
That's so sad.
I don't have that many characters.
My gacha luck in this game is so garble.
Yeah.
But out of rabbit squad, I like, uh...
I like, um, Saki the most.
I really like her helmet.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Need to poll on stream for streamer luck.
We'll see.
I only have 9000 gemies.
So I'm not doing any polling at the moment.
I am waiting.
Who is next?
Who...
What is... Who is next?
New twins are called Hikari and Nozomi?
Ah!
After the shink...
As soon as you said that, I knew!
The Shinkansen!
Oh no, that makes me like them even more!
Wait, Railgun collab is next?
Oh!
I never got Miku, so... Okay.
We'll save for Railgun.
Swimsuit Hina just came up on my screen.
Okay.
Where was I?
Rico, thank you!
Rico, thank you again!
Alex, thank you!
Go mint Nasa!
Kayvarn, thank you!
Pirate6...
Six,
thank you!
Chidontai, thank you!
TheRockboss, thank you!
Thank you for the revengeance definition.
Now we know it's a real word.
Ludus, thank you!
So more dono, more figures.
No!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the pink dono!
No, no, no.
I have just the... well, the Yudokan point is really expensive, so I have been holding off on pre-ordering anything else.
I was like, I will...
I am pacing myself!
Oh, there it is!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the stream- Thank you!
And...
Superchats!
Cha -cha-cha!
Oh my gosh, guys, we are almost to 180,000!
And then, next, 190,000!
And then, maybe 200,000!
That'd be kinda crazy!
That'd be a little lucky!
If that happens!
Are you planning anything for 200,000?
Well...
I...
I didn't...
Well, I don't know.
I don't think we are going to get there so fast.
But I didn't expect to get this far this fast.
So...
I guess I will plan something for 200,000.
I will plan something.
Hmm...
I already have some ideas.
So...
Yes, yes, yes!
I already have some ideas.
And some of them, if I implement them, might take a little bit of long- a bit longer, so...
I have some time, which is good.
Oh my god!
The 50, thank you!
Okie dokie!
As for Superchats...
Chiliax, thank you!
Murphy, hot dog!
Raymac, hot dog!
Seymour, thank you!
We are all ready to hear YubiYubi multiple times.
Well, I hope you had your money's worth.
StarCreator, thank you!
Spank, hot dog!
ClaretFran, thank you!
Today is my birthday!
I wanted to share some joy with my Kamiyoshi ghost mate!
I have pistachio cake and fancy cookies.
Feel free to possess me and eat some!
I will... after stream.
if you feel a chill.
I'm an older lady now, I can't eat as many cookies as I used to.
Don't worry, I will eat some for you.
I'll have just a nibble.
Happy birthday, Claret!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear ClaretFran!
Happy birthday!
Even though I don't have much knowledge or understand much of anything you like, such as blue archive or your feet fetishes, I do like your energy and your passion for your hobbies.
Thanks for always being you for who you are.
Where did the feet thing come from?
No, it's so funny.
I was looking at Little Witch Nobita stuff earlier and there was this one phone stand with her feet out so much but I was like I I her her toes looked like fingers it was like feet!
It made me feel I didn't really like it.
I was like oh my gosh, I feel like I can smell this picture but not in a good way.
Nobita has some interesting merch twitter posts.
Yes they do.
If you...
I'm not gonna put up the picture because something about it makes me uncomfortable.
I don't know what it is.
Don't feet shame.
I'm not!
I'm not feet shaming.
I get it.
Like I get it if you're into feet.
But it's just not my thing.
It's just not my thing.
It really looks like monkey toes.
That's what I'm saying!
Would you be interested in joining my new cafe?
It's called Super Cute Awesome Maids!
AKA Cafe Scam!
Wow!
Oh my gosh and you're all about them.
I can tell you're like a scam kamioshi.
You're just scam.
Wow!
Super Cute Awesome Maids?
Hmmm...
I like it.
Cafe Scam.
S-C-A-M.
Sorry.
Is it not scam?
Is it S-C-A-M?
Sorry.
Respect the hustle.
It sounds so legit.
I mean I'm already in a maid cafe right now.
As you can see.
But I will consider.
Will there be a competitor called F-R-A-U-D?
Hmmm...
Yeah, I mean...
We can't have a monopoly here, right?
There could be S-H-A-M.
Cafe Sham.
Anyway...
Eating Mike Tyson's ass?
Yubi yubi!
Thank you!
Minty Fresh Kyle!
Mint, if you hate us, don't say anything.
Oh, wait.
Something.
Anything.
Wait.
If you don't...
Wait, if you hate us...
Don't say anything.
Oh, I mixed it up.
I thought you meant...
I thought you meant, if you like us...
Say anything.
Wait.
If you hate us, say...
Huh?
I thought, if you don't hate us...
Say anything.
Quit your crying!
I don't wanna see...
I don't wanna see any more of these tears!
Quit your crying!
Quit your crying.
Yeah?
What about it?
Quit your crying.
This is the real world.
This is what you will hear on a daily basis.
Someone will walk up to you on the street and they'll say, Hey, I hate you.
That's just the reality of things.
You gotta be tough.
You gotta be a tough cookie out there.
It's true.
That's messed up.
That's just how life is, man.
Here to gauge your interest in my venture, the freaking rad...
Awesome, ultra delicious cafe.
F-R-A-U-D for short.
Competition.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting too many offers, you guys.
Please.
Please respect my boundaries.
Send it to my email.
Send it to my manager.
A.K.A.
me.
Why do you make us cry?
Stop telling me what to do, VTuber.
Fine.
I won't tell you twice.
Pre-order bonus.
Thank you for the 10.
Thank you so much.
Mint, get a manager.
Okay, but you make it sound so easy.
You make it sound so easy.
Like...
How does one just acquire a manager?
I have to find someone...
First of all, I don't know anybody.
Second of all, I have to find someone...
That...
That's not gonna steal all my information and run away.
Like a Looney Tunes villain.
Okay?
The afterlife is hard.
Ask Mr. Man.
Just call Mr. Man.
The manager's store.
I'm gonna go to a vending machine.
Manager vending machine.
MintyFreshKyle, thank you!
Paperbacks, thank you!
GatoRaffen, thank you!
I feel disturbance in the floors.
MintyFreshKyle, thank you!
MintyFreshKyle, thank you again!
YouTubeGPTChatBot version 1.51 Thank you!
Koro-san is the greatest Vtuber of all time.
All glory to the dog god.
Chatbots are out of hand.
YouTubeGPTChatBot version 1.51?
I wonder what he'll say in version 1.52.
Dog I am.
Wait, are you a chatbot or are you a dog?
Who gave this dog a keyboard?
Thank you, thank you!
May I interest you in super chill amazing managers?
God, I wish.
Finally managed to catch a stream!
A lot of streams overlap with work unfortunately compared to years ago.
Oh no!
But thank you for dropping by when you can.
This mint girl seems like a cute, happy, awesome, really awesome, totally awesome nerd.
Charlotte!
That's quite the praise.
On the internet, nobody knows you are a dog.
Eating Mike Tyson's butt.
Thank you!
Hi mint, I'm excited to watch that.
I hope your day is going well.
Actually it's so funny.
A friend of mine was just like, what's up with that eating Mike Tyson's butt guy?
Why does everyone always say legend, legend every time he comes up?
And so I actually, I showed them the clip of Korone saying your name.
And her just going, no!
So I watched it again recently.
So yeah.
Fancy seeing you!
Thanks for dropping by so often.
Evan's kazoo covers.
Thank you!
Is this Halo 2?
Not enough chief.
Second soul.
Thank you!
Did you play Death Must Die?
Matara liked it a lot.
Also thank you!
I'm listening while halfway through a 6-7 mile walk and regretting it.
Regretting the stream or regretting the walk?
Which one?
Which one are you regretting?
Hey mint, you seem super into Metal Gear.
We all know the real reason to play MGS though.
For shipping!
Who's your favorite pair and who's your favorite rare pair?
Favorite pair is Big Boss and Ocelot.
Rare pair.
Rare
pair.
Dirty pair.
Rare pair?
Rare pair.
Rare pair...?
Miller-Naomi.
Miller-Naomi?
They don't even know each other.
Rare pair...
Oh!
Obviously Vamp and Naomi.
Vamp and Naomi.
Great couple.
My favorite rare pair.
Eww.
Yuck.
I almost choked on my drink.
Vamp and Riot and Naomi.
What are you talking about?
It's the best rare pair.
Rico, thank you!
I'm glad you're enjoying your Helldivers training.
Actually, Mataro is trying to organize a Helldivers collab.
Because I've been wanting to play it.
So yeah, good training.
I know that it will be so useful.
Oh, actually I should play it.
I should play MGS5 again.
For actual training.
Hey MF, it's Piccolo again.
Dirty pair of what?
Of socks.
Dirty pair of socks.
Wash your socks everybody.
Thank you!
Thank you again!
This game really makes you feel like Touhou.
Oh, I felt the Touhou.
Thank you!
Thank you, I think.
Eleven seems to be my lucky number.
That was one of the achievements I got.
I just realized the time.
You guys, I gotta put it together on my desk.
I mean, my furniture.
So let's say I'm happy to see you back again.
I've loved every stream.
I don't talk much in chat, but every stream has been so much fun.
Aww, thank you.
Happy to be back.
I have a lot of fun every day, so thank you guys.
Lenguinihududu.
That's such an awesome name.
Sucks you have to be the second one though.
Shelf building stream.
Dogs drinks, thank you.
Jolly Ram Rancher, thank you.
Inane, thank you.
LeahD, thank you.
X21, thank you.
95...
Intract?
Did I say that right?
Thank you.
Slimekin, thank you.
Galactic Core, thank you.
Reynard, thank you.
Rhea, thank you.
Nushi Sushi, thank you.
Ice Dream, thank you.
Gato Reffen, thank you.
Gato Reffen, thank you again.
LeahD, thank you.
VeroLint, thank you.
FarTheKiller, thank you.
StarCreator, thank you.
LimoLimo, thank you.
Genos.
HelloConnoisseur, thank you.
Sorry, I was making sure I said your...
Did I say your name right?
I hope so.
If you don't hate us, don't say...
Wait.
If you don't hate us...
Wait, oh no!
FlashMessage.
You're welcome.
Speaking of figures, I recently got my Miku 15th Anniversary Shortcake figure.
It's so cute.
Wait, I don't know if I've seen that one before.
Google.
Oh my god, it's beautiful!
Oh my gosh, it's beautiful!
It's so pretty.
Oh my god, the base is a plate.
What scale is she?
Oh my god, the price on it.
Wait, the price!
What scale is she?
1 seventh.
Sheesh.
She is so cute.
Oh my gosh, the macaron too is so... everything is so cute.
Yeah,
you guys, I said it.
It means I don't hate you guys.
Stop crying.
I should un-private the... I don't think I had the flash message on my...
You know, I had a tongue twister video.
I should un-private it.
It's kind of cringe hearing me from so long ago.
She hates us.
Love seeing different games.
Hope you keep having a lot of fun with them.
Replay Tokyo Jungle after you mention it.
I should play Tokyo Jungle, shouldn't I?
I should, I should.
I can play whatever I want.
That's the craziest thing.
If there's something I want to play, the day it comes out, I can play it.
I can play whatever I want.
Whatever.
Actually, that's a lie.
There are some things that I will stay away from.
That I kind of want to play, but I won't.
Because I'm scared of Nintendo.
Like if it's like a Pokemon mod, I won't.
I probably won't play it.
I've seen that a lot of channels have been getting struck.
I've heard other VTubers complaining that there's actually too little MGS fanfiction.
Is this true?
I don't read fanfiction.
But I have talked about this with a friend where we were like...
We were like...
When the Master Collection comes out, maybe all the girlies will be like, Yes!
This is it!
This is the game!
This is the series!
And there will be so much more doujin.
But, unfortunately...
It hasn't...
At least from what I've noticed, it hasn't changed much.
So...
Like I went to Comiket last year.
I went to Winter Comiket.
And there was only a few tables with MGS doujin.
And they were all...
They were all like, from 5.
So it was a little disappointing.
So sad.
Thank you!
Thank you for all the gifted dono...
Gifted memberships!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you!
Greetings from Germany!
What time is it?
Guten...
Guten Tag.
I don't know.
Wait, it's...
It's really late there.
What time in Germany?
1AM in Germany.
Guten Nacht.
Guten Nacht!
Yes.
Auf... Auf...
Oh gosh, don't let her hear me say this.
Aufs...
Don't let her hear me say it.
Auf...
Don't... Don't let her hear me say it.
She's gonna come for me, you guys.
She's gonna come for me.
Auf wieder...
Auf... Hold on.
Someone put it...
Auf... Auf...
Auf...
Where did it go?
Auf... Auf...
Wait, where did it go?
Auf...
Someone broke it apart.
Where did it go?
Auf... Flash?
Stop, stop, stop.
Auf... Auf...
Auf...
Auf wiedersehen.
Auf....
Auf...
Anyway...
Yeah, this means you should go to bed.
Galactic .
Thank you.
Hi, Minty.
No time, no super chat.
You look gorgeous as ever.
Auf...
Thank you.
a lot of thanks.
Refresh.
Also, Pirate606, thank you!
I read your dono, but I didn't thank you.
Thank you so much.
Auf Wiedersehen!
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Your German is cute, greeting.
Greetings from another German wisp.
Is that why I can't say your name right?
I mean, see you later.
Yeah, I'm telling you to go to sleep!
I'm telling you to go to sleep!
Oh wait, where did I leave off on?
Oh, oh, oh, here we go.
Rodrigo, thank you!
What a great way to spend my cozy Sunday, relaxing with mint and Coronet.
Thanks for another fun stream.
Thank you!
Resting Glitch Face, thank you!
Think I may have stolen some of your luck.
Was playing a similar game, Kill the Crows, and got six unlocks in ten minutes.
Gomen na sai.
That's okay.
I forgive you.
Actually, I don't forgive you.
I don't forgive you.
I'm going to haunt you.
I'm going to haunt you until you give me my luck back.
That was weird.
What was happening?
Oh, Customer Johnson, thank you!
Wow, it's Doug.
Hi, Doug!
Just scam.
Thank you!
You got it.
You got some competition up in here.
I'm just saying.
But there's, you know...
Potware, thank you!
Ego Jojo.
Pocky Donut, thank you!
Maggish, thank you!
You can hate me any day.
Stop.
Hollow, my baby, thank you!
Teacup and Nyan Nyan, thank you!
No, stop crying.
Nexi Dava, thank you!
Niels Wouter, thank you!
Cheggie, thank you!
Sionios, thank you!
Just Scam, thank you!
Karma Strikes, thank you!
Rico, thank you!
Katrina Dungle, thank you!
It's a Bow Wow world out there.
So true.
Zazzamos, thank you!
Hot Dog, where do I sign up for a haunting?
You know, that's the fun part about it.
Just by being here, you sign up.
Sometimes, I might come and possess you a little bit.
A little.
When you least expect a possession, it will arrive.
Piccolo, thank you!
Hakunon Matata, thank you!
Or Hakunon... Hakunon Matata?
I guess that makes more sense, right?
David Titanium Peepy Dog, thank you!
Gliss, thank you!
Super G, thank you!
Is Johnny and Bathroom a rare pair since he hardly makes it?
Actually, I do like Johnny and Meryl.
So maybe that's like a...
It's like a...
No!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
My favorite...
My favorite rare pair is Raiden and Rose.
How?
How could I forget them?
The most powerful couple in the world.
They are my favorite toxic couple ever.
Oh my gosh.
I live for Raiden and Rose drama.
I love it so much.
It's so fun!
They're such a great...
It's my favorite telenovela ever.
Sketch, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Egotistical woman.
Does that count as a rare pair?
Maybe because I don't think many people ship them.
I don't think many people ship them.
What did I enter to?
I'm just reading donuts.
Weeaboo, let's thank you!
Fukuro-chan, thank you!
Karateka, thank you!
Please don't possess or hunt me while I'm on the toilet.
That would be embarrassing.
For me.
Thank you.
I don't want to do that.
So I think you're safe.
Red Ranger, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh no, I'm possessed.
Oh no, my ten dollars turning into figurine funds.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Stop it!
Don't do it!
Where was I?
Lilia, Seraphina, thank you!
I have no idea how much joy you bring me.
And everyone's seeing you laugh, smile, and just being yourself every time you stream.
Thank you.
Thank you!
So nice of you.
Thank you.
Fleur Deli is gaming.
Definitely think I said that wrong.
But thank you so much.
I'll...
No, no.
Not the schnitzel.
Eintracht, thank you!
Go to sleep.
Niels Water, thank you!
How can we sleep when our commie...
Oh, she is streaming.
No!
I will try and do...
Try and do...
EU friendly time this week.
The salt word gun goes...
Yes!
Ouch!
Stop!
Why would you send that?
Ouch!
Why would you do that?
I think I should go to sleep.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to yell.
Um...
Ninja Tim, thank you!
Greetings from Austria, too.
Guten nacht!
Um...
Linguini Houdini.
Made inugami phantom.
Nope.
Why?
Thank you.
Nicole, thank you!
Rodrigo, thank you!
Rico, hot dog!
Kaito, thank you!
Nicole, I don't know why I get this feeling...
But like...
Are you my girlfriend?
Did I...
Possess someone...
Um...
And ask you out?
I don't know.
Stop!
Stop sending me salt!
Stop it!
I am not...
That's why I'm not salty at all because...
I am not salty at all...
Because it will literally kill me, you guys.
You guys.
I think someone I possessed asked you out, Nicole.
I don't know why I feel like that.
But anyway...
Oh my gosh,
the salt!
Customer Johnson, thank you!
Wrestling Glitchface, thank you!
Osos!
Wiresun!
Paperbacks!
Pocky Donut!
Kenja!
Baby Paladin!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Amelia Zhang!
Yeah, like a snail!
Wild and Stuck!
Wrong for Rabbit!
Have you noticed a change in behavior?
Do Metal Gear and...
Idle Goods arrive that you don't remember ordering?
You may have been possessed by Maid Mint Phantom!
Don't complain!
You're a lucky person!
TalkTalk, thank you!
You guys are literally killing me.
Fake Knee!
Yuki Baskerville!
What about Pepper?
No, that's okay.
Thanks, DingusCon!
Take up NyanNyan!
The Nain!
Right back!
Why are you guys doing this to me?
I'm turning off Donut right now.
Turn.
Off.
I understand the implications of this action.
Turn.
Off.
Perfect.
Okay, now I refresh.
Refresh.
Ash and Sloth.
Sketch the Cartoon Guy!
The podcast is a hoot!
If you're still thinking of haunting a grocery store on the side, let me tell you, working retail is hell.
I know.
I have done it.
Um...
I don't know quite yet.
Part of me is just like, things are stressful, and I just wanna go back to having a normal job, so I don't have to think about it.
But...
You know.
Oh...
Literally 1984.
Totally salted.
She hates us.
Stop your crying.
Just...
Stop crying!
Stop your crying!
Does it work with kosher or fortified salt?
I think it's just any salt.
What is a fortified salt?
Anyway...
Murphy game over!
That's it everybody!
Go home!
Spank, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Nebula, thank you for the gifted!
I'm gonna go... oh my gosh.
I suddenly got super hungry.
So I'm gonna go eat.
I'm gonna go have dinner.
And I suggest the same for you guys.
Also, I see you in the Streamlabs.
Gaea and Chiron-cha.
I see you both.
I see you.
I see you, I see you, I see you.
Otsuminto!
Everybody!
I'm just gonna leave because I'm...
starting to get shaky hungry.
I'm hungry!
Let's have...
a good meal.
Otsuminto!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for another fun stream!
Not tomorrow because tomorrow is...
Well, I will see you on the podcast.
If you listen, please listen.
Yes.
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much as always!
Bye!